[Musik]
ja wenn man diese Bilder sieht dann ist
man schockiert es ist hemmungslose
Brutalität wie man einstellt hier seht
sehen Sie das Video in der Schule und
auf dem Boden liegt wieder Leonie und
das war nicht nur zwei Videos es waren
mehrere und ich habe diese Videos alle
gesehen und ich habe gestern Leonie im
Arm gehabt ich habe ihre Mutter im Arm
gehabt und ich bin nach Rastatt gefahren
und auch nach Karlsruhe um dort ein
Zeichen zu setzen für Leonie und für
jedes Kind was unter Mobbing und Gewalt
leidet was man da sieht ist kein
bedauerliche Einzelfall wie man uns
immer weiß machen will besonders die
Verantwortliche in der Politik das ist
die Realität in unserem Land und das ist
jetzt nicht ein Fall von Rastatt das ist
überall und ich mache das jetzt
neuneinhalb Jahre und ich sehe das immer
wieder und der einzige Weg daraus ist
Offenheit offen über die Missstände
sprechen offen über die Probleme
sprechen und Präventionen Aufklärung
verbote bringen gar nichts und schauen
Sie mal da ist das Bild ich bin gestern
da runtergefahren war ein Tag vor Ort
ich habe die Politik eingeladen ich habe
mit gesagt komm lass uns was machen ja
aber wenn ihr es nicht macht macht ich
bin da runtergefahren habe dafür gesorgt
dass Menschen sich weil hier auch nicht
stellen dass die Leute hat sie ist jetzt
in einem in einem in einem Boxclub mit
vielen hunderten von Menschen wir haben
mit ihr zusammengesetzt die kann in
diesem Boxclub Freunde finden sie kann
da trainieren um sich und
Selbstbewusstsein zu bekommen und vor
allen Dingen Leute zu haben und dann
waren diese alle gemeinsam haben in
dieses Zeichen gesetzt und wenn ich dann
und ich will das nur kurz Vorlesen was
mir heute die Mama geschrieben hat
Jessica hat sich richtig gefreut und ich
habe sie schon lange nicht mehr so
gesehen sie bekommt jetzt Aufmerksamkeit
nach der Sie sich schon immer gesehen
hat und schon und die sich schon immer
wollte und bei anderen suchte was dann
aber immer schiefgehen und das schreibt
mir die Mutter die seit Monaten Angst um
ihr Kind hat wenn sie das Haus verlässt
jessica wurde dort eine Falle gelockt
sie hat bei Instagram Freunde gesucht
jessica ist ein Geschenk sie hat eine
emotionale Störung sie kann sich nicht
so verhalten man hat sie angeschrieben
man hat sie angenommen aber sie vorher
noch nie da hat man sie im Hinterhalt
und die die sich schon vorher verprügelt
haben haben sie dann wieder verprügelt
sie ist der punching Ball von dieser
Region und ich habe so die Schnauze voll
von einer Politik die das verhindern
will und wissen sie und jetzt kommen
aber dazu als als ich rumgesprochen habe
als ich ein Video gemacht habe dass ich
da hinkommen hat doch der Schulleiter an
einer Schule nichts besseres zu tun als
den Schüler zu sagen geht nicht dahin
spricht nicht mit Karsten Stahl und eine
Eltern bei Vorsitzende die mit mir den
Gespräch suchte um mich an die Schule zu
holen wurde der Mund verboten kann als
belegen das solltet ihr euch mal
überlegen was ihr da macht er kann das
alles veröffentlichen mit dämlich muss
man sein aber noch mal ich habe die
Schnauze so voll ich mache das hier seit
neuneinhalb Jahren aber es gibt zum
Glück auch genug Schulleiter die
mittlerweile sich dem Thema annehmen
aber solange wir die Hälfte aller Schule
an Deutschland das sind zumindestens
16.000 sagt an unserer Schule gibt's
kein Mobbing wird sich nichts ändern
aber es ist das politische Versagen das
totschweigen und immer wieder der
gleiche Weg oh jetzt sind jetzt sind wir
negativ in der Presse jetzt warte mal ab
bis der Erdbeben vorbei ist und dann
machen wir weiter wie bisher wenn ich
jetzt da nicht hingefahren wäre die
hätten nichts gemacht oh stimmt nicht
der Bürgermeister hat ja heute ein
Artikel gemacht
wir machen wir wir brauchen mehr Kameras
auf dem auf dem Bahnhof von Rastatt
wirklich Meister wirklich wo warst du
denn gestern war ein bisschen
hingekommen was machst denn für
Prävention ach so habe ich ja gemacht ja
Geschehen Rechnung kommt es kotzt mich
an ganz klarer Vorwurf von Carsten Stahl
Richtung Politik das Wegschauen der
Politik lass uns einmal über die ganz
wichtige Frage sprechen wie geht es
Jessica wie geht es auch der Mutter du
hast darüber berichtet dass sie um ihr
Kind fürchten musste wenn Jessica 14
Jahre alt sie sich noch nichts mehr
gesehen hat als nach Freunden und
Nachteile sie hatte keine und natürlich
willst du ein Kind auch raus sie ist 14
dann nimmt sie lieber Freundschaften an
zu falschen Freunden die sie danach
kurze Zeit misshandeln und Filmen sie
geht auf diesen Marktplatz wo sie immer
wieder Attacken ausgeliefert sie sitzt
da mit ihrer Musikbox und die Kinder
kommen auf Sie zu und dann folgen der
Kinder und das will ich immer wieder
sagen sie folgen der Gruppen Dynamik sie
folgen dieser gruppennamit sie wollen
dazu gehören auch ein Elternteil von
einem der Täter hat sich bei gemeldet
und deshalb bitte auch mein Kind braucht
hilfe das habe ich in allen Videos
gesagt wir müssen nicht nur Jessica
helfen sondern wir müssen auch den
Tätern helfen weil die Täter Folgen der
gruppennamik und wenn wir jetzt die
nicht einfangen und das nehme ich alle
Kinder die sich so verhalten dann werden
die später die die noch schlimmere
Straftaten machen sie sind Kinder woher
weiß ich dass ich war Opfer und die
Katheter ich war selber jemand der sich
so verhalten hat aber immer wieder
Kürze zum Kopf auf eine am Boden
liegende Person wird wird als Mord
versucht gewertet weil diese Personen in
Kauf nehmen das schwere Verletzung sogar
der Tod eintritt und hier muss man
handeln hier macht man nicht so tun als
wenn das Problem ist und noch mal ich
kann ja jedes mal hinfahren in eure
Städte und die Probleme lösen ja aber es
ist eigentlich nicht meine Aufgabe
gewählten Volksvertreter vor 20
Millionen bekommen ja ich kann mich aber
Feuer und am Arsch machen weil Kurven
brauchen wir da da setzt euch am
gleichen Tag zusammen mit den Schulen
und redet über das Problem na ja
vielleicht kommt ja auch als Sinn weil
bei raus ihr könnt mich jederzeit
anrufen ich helfe euch gerne den
Problemen zu lösen oder ihr macht
alleine aber
gerade genickt haben Sie das Gefühl dass
wir eine zunehmende Verrohung der
Gesellschaft erleben das ist immer
brutaler wird schon bei Kindern
kassenstahl hat geschrieben gerade
beschrieben die dritte gegen den Kopf
dass da gar keine ja keine Schranke
besteht kann aufhören besteht wenn
jemand auf dem Boden liegt keine
Beißhemmung mehr ich habe mir gedacht
jetzt haben wir immer über einen Krieg
geredet über Ukraine kriegt aber er
beginnt der inzwischen Situation in
klar die Vorwürfe von der Politik sind
da dass sie schlechte Schulleiter gibt
und gute Schulleiter das ist mir auch
aber ich glaube die Notwendigkeit dass
wir
auf die Jugendlichen einwirken können
hat auch was natürlich mit einer
sozialen Gerechtigkeit zu tun ist sollte
das Thema sein was sie dann hier
vielleicht heute mitbringen will merken
Armut hat nicht nur was mit dem
Kleingeld im Geldbeutel zu tun sondern
Armut ist flächendeckend aber betrifft
alles betrifft die Lebensweise aber
betrifft die Bildung betrifft
die der der den sozialen Status und eben
dann ob Gewalt oder nicht aber da wird
wissen sie da wird am wenigsten
investiert schauen wir mal der Weg um
das zu verhindern sind keine Verbote
sondern Präventionen und Aufklärung
mache ich seit neuneinhalb Jahren vor
wie kein zweiter muss mir gehen aber
erzählen wie Berichte sprechen für sich
aber anstatt daraus zu lernen zu
partizipieren mittlerweile bildet ja
auch weiter Lehrer und Erzieher aber es
geht immer wieder und zu den Lehrern und
die Direktoren von oben im Stich
gelassen viele sagen mir Herr Stahl wir
würden ja aber wissen Sie wenn wir sagen
wir haben Probleme stehen als Problem
Schule da und die die nicht sagen das
Problem haben stehen besser da sie
werden im Stich gelassen und wenn man es
dann aufkommt heißt immer nur der böse
böse böse Katzenstein und die böse böse
Zeitung ihr wollt nicht loswerden wie
wird dann einfach nehmen die Missstände
los macht dann muss ich weniger machen
kann mir meine Kinder sehen nein in
Deutschland ist immer der gefährlicher
der die Mitte anspricht als der die
nämlich schon gemacht und zu
verantworten habt ihr macht sie zu
beantworten und Ecke und andere diese
lösen wollen wir sind die Bilder
wegschauen auch finde ich ihrem Kind in
diesem Video das Thema Zivilcourage
Nickel wir haben gerade eben gesehen
dieses Video da wird gefilmt keine
greift rein trauen wir uns das nicht
mehr würden sie eingreifen ja da aber
natürlich muss man eingreifen wenn man
wenn man in einer solchen Situation ist
und ich
sehe in diesem Binde schockiert von von
diesen Bildern und natürlich ist es
wichtig dass man da versucht etwas
dagegen zu tun was mich interessieren
würde als ähm nicht Fachmann wie sehr
Stahl
was hat das eigentlich mit den Familien
zu tun ja also
mit den Familien aus denen aus denen die
Schläger kommen ja also kann man den
kann man denn da nicht vielleicht auch
ein bisschen also ein bisschen helfen
also grundsätzlich ist es so die Kinder
sind ja nur genauso wie alle die Summe
ihre Erlebnisse und grundsätzlich muss
heißt es nicht nur weil jemand
vielleicht aus sozial schwachen
Verhältnissen kommt dass er zum
Gewalttäter wird ja ähm man muss aber
anfangen dass man den Kindern wieder
Werte vermittelt unsere Gesellschaft
vermittelt keine Werte mehr schon gar
nicht den die ihre Zukunft sind wir
spielen ihn immer wer weiter vor höher
schneller weiter Ellbogen ausfahren und
Hauptsache bitte und wir haben in diese
Waffe gegeben das ist nämlich eine Waffe
in den falschen Händen wie wir hier
wieder sehen und grundsätzlich ist diese
fehlende cd-garage ja nicht nur bei den
Kindern es gibt ein Video wo wieder
andere 20 Meter weg stehen und die Film
und dann lachen sie unter Feuer das
ganze noch keiner möchte zum Opfer
werden oh ich habe nichts gesehen bloß
ich die steigen ja mittlerweile über
Menschen darüber weg die am Boden liegen
und ich fordere dass unsere Gesellschaft
sich wieder verändert aber darf ich mal
kurz ein Beispiel geben warum es so ist
da steht drauf Sexismus Skandale von
Dieter Bohlen Mobbing auf höchster Ebene
im Fernsehen wird er mobbt er und macht
eine Frau runter und beleidigt die
sexistisch wenn dies in den
Fernsehsendung wie Dschungelcamp oder
DSDS oder sowas oder was auch immer
machen wo sollen die Kinder die Werte
her haben wo sollen sie denn wenn die
Pommes mitmachen können wo sollen sie
denn wenn man alle darf ja wir müssen
wieder Werte vermitteln wir müssen den
Menschen Menschlichkeit verlieren und
nur mal so nebenbei halt jetzt vergessen
habt Artikel 1 das Grundgesetzes die
Würde des Menschen ist unantastbar haben
sie gehört wird angeprangert man kann
sich verprügelt auf die brutalste Art
und Weise das was im Fernsehen passiert
Fragezeichen
ich glaube schon und wenn dann haben die
falsche Vorbilder das ist im Fernseher
mit diesen ganzen gewaltfilmen und
Schießereien und so weiter
kann man natürlich haben wir auch das
Riesenproblem mit der Schießerei aber es
gibt es muss sie sagen leider in
Deutschland diese Kultur des der guten
Gewalt oder schlechten Gewalt wenn sie
jetzt eng mit wieder in an kohlengruber
die Polizei verprügeln oder wenn sie auf
die Krankenwagen mit mit
einem Feuerlöscher schmeißen
gut das wird nicht gut geheißen aber
diese diese Gewalt ist auch politisch
wird die dann akzeptiert diese
straßenkleber die dann andere Leute
behindern zur Arbeit zu kommen da ist
jemand gestorben war ein
unfallkrankenwagen ist nicht angekommen
und so weiter und da heißt es ja aber
das ist legitim äh natürlich bin
entsetzt was Herr Stahl jetzt erzählt
hat und und gezeigt hat
bin aber natürlich ist nicht Fachmann
aber klar ähm ein das zu Hause
sollte eigentlich dazu dienen dass man
den Kindern entsprechenden Respekt
gegenüber an den Menschen und an den
Kindern beibringt es gibt gute Gewalt
die These in Deutschland was glauben sie
herrschen
ist nicht schwarz-weiß haben wir ja in
der Diskussion panzerlieferung die
konnisierung es ist so nur gut und so
nur schlecht ich werde immer auch den
Weg des Kompromisses gehen ich würde
sagen zu diesem Thema zur Abrundung das
hoffnungsvolle ist wir wissen was zu tun
ist für mich soziale Infrastruktur das
man vielleicht irgendwann einmal so früh
wie mit sein für die Rüstung brauchen
einmal Infrastruktur reinstecken ja nur
die Prävention wir müssen mehr
reinstecken und dann können wir mit
solchen Phänomenen dann bei abrechnen
dann können sie sagen das ist bei uns
kann nicht an der Tagesordnung aber das
gilt dafür Amerika ganz genauso wie für
uns ich habe ein ganz tollen Satz gehört
in dieser Woche in der
das hier ob das hier ob
Armut in unsere Gesellschaft wir sind
alle in demselben Sturm damit sitzen
nicht alle im selben Boot und das müssen
wir zusammenbringen dass wir die Leute
ins Boot reinholen und wir das ist kein
kein Unternehmen des scheitern muss wie
haben das in der Hand